Disney is doing their best to keep the
plot line of frozen to under wraps and
for the most part they've managed to do
just that
we've got some ideas about where Anna
and Elsa are going and some of them make
a little too much sense watch until the
end to find out why the people of
arendelle might have to flee their
hometown the frozen - trailer is
action-packed dark and oh so mysterious
still it managed to leave us with more
questions than answer as frozen fans are
trying to find out where Elsa Anna and
the entire gang are going but only
handful of theories seem to make any
sense of all the beginning of the
trailer starts off with Elsa trying to
freeze the ocean and run across it
fans have theorized that Elsa is stuck
on an island of some sorts while others
simply believe her to be training for an
upcoming threat to brands new characters
have entered the franchise and we might
just know who these people are fall is
coming to arendelle amongst other things
and our heroes look absolutely
determined but where are they going the
past Elsa and Anna are forced to grow up
alone when their parents suffered an
unexpected shipwreck before the events
of frozen ever took place seeing as they
passed away when Elsa and Anna were so
young we wouldn't be surprised if one of
the sisters medals with magic should get
them back the ex king of arendelle knew
a thing or two about magic which is why
he contacted the trolls when Anna got
hurt so what if Elsa used a spell to
turn back time to stop her parents from
boarding the ship go into the past is a
tricky thing
so Elsa might have miscalculated and
ended up going way back in time some
fans believe that actors Evan Rachel
Wood and sterling K Brown will be
playing younger versions of Queen Adina
and King a ganar respectively if you
think about it their parents do look a
lot like the kids we see in the trailer
so here's what we think might happen
Elsa in the entire gang are going back
in time to stop their parents from
boarding the ship only to meet them in
their kid forms then the gang will help
Agner and I do not save the kingdom of
arendelle from an upcoming threat frozen
fans have no clue who this threat could
be but we do know that they have fiery
powers without Elsa's ice powers
arendelle wouldn't be able to beat their
rival which is why Elsa traveling to the
past is so important by doing so not
only is she saving arendelle but she's
also ensuring that
parents know that they will have two
daughters Elsa and Anna and that one of
them will have powers
this theory comes full circle which is
why we'd like it but there's another
theory that has our attention and it
doesn't involve time travel which we can
all agree is a little less messy going
to Denmark as many of you know the
frozen franchise was inspired by Hans
Christian Andersen's fairy tale The Snow
Queen this Danish tell was published in
1845 and has long since become a popular
story so much so that Disney chose to
mold Elsa and Anna off of the main
characters from Anderson's tale despite
taking place in the Disney verse its
belief that arendelle is actually
located in Norway which is pretty close
to Denmark and since the Snow Queen
takes place in Denmark we believe that
Elsa Anna and the game will be journey
into this faraway land to put an end to
the snow Queens evil ways at the
beginning of the trailer we see Elsa
trying to freeze the ocean and run
across it since the fastest way to
Denmark from Norway is by the sea it
makes sense that she would want to try
taking this route however the ocean is a
force to be reckoned with
which is why taking the long way is best
[Music]
The Snow Queen The Snow Queen starts off
by telling the story of a wicked wizard
who created an evil mirror that showed
people the bad and ugly in their
reflection he wanted to show it to the
entire world so he flew up to the
heavens however once at a high altitude
the mirror began to shake until it
shattered little shards of glass fell
onto the earth infecting innocent people
by the hundreds and should anyone ever
get a shard in their eye they would see
the world through a dark lens for
eternity The Snow Queen tells the tale
of two best friends Ty and Goethe who
gets separated when a shard of glass
enters Kai's I the Snow Queen finds Kai
and brings him home to Lapland where he
becomes her servant The Snow Queen is
about Gerdes quest to free her friends
by showing him what the power of love
can do Disney chose to turn the Snow
Queen into Elsa and Gerda into Anna they
tweaked the story and made it about
sisterly love however some fans believe
The Snow Queen still exists and that
she's up to no good
it's possible that the glowing rhombuses
we see in the trailer are fragments of
the evil mirror if this is the case it
makes sense that the gang is traveling
to Denmark
aka Lapland to stop The Snow Queen from
taking over the world
frozen co-director Jennifer Lee did
reveal that the sequel was going to be
bigger and more epic than the first and
she also said that the characters were
going to go far out of arendelle good
did Mark B what our heroes are gazing at
in the distance fans seem to think so
they also believe that Evan Rachel Wood
and Stirling K Brown are going to be
playing Gerda and pie respectively this
would tie a Nelson on a story with The
Snow Queen which would be super
interesting
despite stemming from that very same
fairy tale it's believed that frozen two
will finally explain how Elsa got her
ice powers could she be related to the
Snow Queen somehow despite having a bad
reputation it's possible that the Snow
Queen also has a shard of evil mirror in
her eyes which could be what turned her
into such a malevolent ruler in the
first place our honor Elsa and the gang
traveling back in time to help their
parents conquer an upcoming threat for
are they traveling to Lapland to help
Kai and Gerta save their people from The
Snow Queen let us know what your
verdicts are in the comments section
below and that's a wrap give this video
a big thumbs up if you're excited to
watch frozen - and before you go don't
forget to subscribe
to the things for the latest Disney news
thanks for watching we'll catch you next
time
[Music]